a troubling but sadly predictable report
on the coronavirus pandemic's
devastating impact on school children
new test results show a significant drop
in test scores and learning for
elementary school aged children a
national report shows the largest
decline in decades for reading and for
the first time math scores have gone
down the math and the reading scores are
definitely down there's many parents
within fairfax county that have noticed
that i know
personally for my kids mostly the
reading score
we had a hard time with my third grader
his report card last year end of the
year was below grade reading level we
were focused on him and tr how to um
close the gap and get him caught up well
in the age group generation kindergarten
to this year's third grade
it affected more because they're early
learners
the mask did not help
with
visual learning and uh hearing the
teachers speak
on the computer did not help at all it
affected um my dog my oldest daughter
socially
she was depressed isolated
uh when they
the teachers had asked to um show your
face on the camera she did not many kids
did not want to show their face on the
camera so you didn't know what was going
on half of them were probably sleeping
i think overall it affected our county
socially and academically if something
go happens again
i won't be doing virtual again i will
consider homeschooling
but as far as what they're teaching last
year i got a little taste of it
of the curriculum i did not like it
i think school should be focused on
academics math reading scores
versus other things that should be left
at the house
school should be left
be learning your main subjects reading
math
science and social studies
my kids teachers have been amazing and
they put all their effort into my kids
however i've heard other kids teachers
that don't
a lot of school boards across the nation
and especially ours
i don't think they really um put effort
into the kids education enough versus
politics
i honestly think the the school boards
are
very selfish i don't think they have
best interests of kids at all
have gone to the school board meetings
and
they
promote more of the politics in the
schools and they have yet to talk about
what are or concerned about reading and
math scores
i watch weingarten and
for my observation
it feels very more of force control
versus let the parents make the decision
for what's best for their family
it wasn't her choice to close the
schools it was definitely a choice by
the counties and the states to close the
schools
i also think it's a lot of the teachers
unions forcing a lot of this on
in the schools
and a lot of the parents don't like it
parents should be informed in their kids
education and in the schools i
definitely want to know what's going on
in the schools
we have gone so far down i have high
standards for my kids academically
and it'd be very nice if they could
focus more on math
and reading
i think parents need to get more
involved in
in their kids a bit learning abilities
and
if their kids are struggling definitely
reach out but i think the school board
should put focus into it how can we get
these kids caught up because i have yet
to hear about that